TINA SRIVASTAVA: I think it's a
really basic point of curiosity
in the world, and
people that come to MIT,
who are very passionate and
want to change the world,
should know how airplanes
fly, some information
about aviation, and the
incredible feat of humankind
to be able to fly
through the air.
SARAH HANSEN: Today on the
podcast, we're talking flight,
specifically how a course
has been designed and refined
to allow hundreds of students
to pursue a path toward flying.
TINA SRIVASTAVA: I thought
that it was really important
that any student that's
interested in this
have the opportunity to
learn about airplanes
and learn how to become
a pilot themselves.
SARAH HANSEN: Welcome to
"Chalk Radio," a podcast
about inspired teaching at MIT.
I'm your host, Sarah Hansen,
from MIT OpenCourseWare.
In this episode, we'll be
talking about MIT's flight
school with two of its
instructors, Philip Greenspun
and Tina Srivastava.
In our conversation, they share
how a number of innovations
have made the course
incredibly popular,
both in and outside
of the MIT community.
Part of why we want to
highlight this class
is that its
evolution has allowed
for a nimbleness of
structure without sacrificing
the effectiveness
of its instruction.
It's truly fascinating
that something
as seemingly technical
as flight school
can take so many
different shapes.
I wanted to dig into how it's
possible to find flexibility
in instruction with
such high risks
and, also, what made this course
so successful at attracting
and preparing future pilots.
We'll pick up our conversation
with Philip and Tina explaining
what it means to have
access to flight school
and what it really
takes to take flight.
PHILIP GREENSPUN:
People have been
wanting to fly for
thousands of years,
and only in the
last 100 years has
it become a practical reality.
And the US is unique, in
that it's half or a third
of the price here and much
easier to do in the US
than any other country.
So as long as people are here
in the US for whatever reason,
they're never going
to be probably
more than half an hour's
drive, or an hour's drive,
from a flight school.
They're going to
have the ability just
as an ordinary consumer
with a credit card
to spend 5 or 10 hours
mastering the basics of flying.
So one thing that I've
tried to stress in the class
is that they don't have to
commit to getting an FAA Pilot
Certificate, which means
that you're safe to be
the only pilot in the aircraft.
You can go down to
the flight school.
You can get your
hands on the controls,
and within 5 or 10
hours, learn to take off,
fly around, land without
the instructor having
to touch anything
or say anything,
and that's doable for both
airplanes and helicopters.
Just motivating people to
try to get up in the air
and enjoy this unusual freedom
that we have here in the US.
I jumped in as part of
the staff a year ago,
and I have spent about a month
going through the PowerPoints
to emphasize that this
is an activity that
can be done safely, especially
with a two-pilot crew.
Maybe it's the instructor
and the student,
or maybe it's a certificated
pilot and another friend
who happens also to be a pilot.
So I did that, and some
of it was just wording.
People naturally who are
pilots, unfortunately, they'll
tend to stress the hazards
and how they avoided them.
I think part of it is it makes
them seem more impressive.
So there were a
lot of PowerPoints
that says, well, they had
the form of, you will die,
if you will do X. So I
just edited them to say,
you'll be safe, if you do not X.
SARAH HANSEN: Right.
PHILIP GREENSPUN: But
it was still hard.
We had a guest lecturer who's
an aerobatics instructor.
SARAH HANSEN: OK.
PHILIP GREENSPUN:
He spent some time
talking about the hazards
of midair collisions
and how people avoid them,
but if you look at the data,
that's only 2% of accidents.
It's not a common way to
have an accident at all.
SARAH HANSEN: OK.
PHILIP GREENSPUN: Why
scare people about it?
Obviously, it's good
to avoid any accident.
SARAH HANSEN: Right.
PHILIP GREENSPUN: But he didn't
share with the students, look,
I'm telling you about something
that accounts for only 2%
of accidents.
SARAH HANSEN: Right.
PHILIP GREENSPUN: They're
sitting there terrified
that they'll be flying along,
and all of a sudden, somebody
will smash into them.
SARAH HANSEN: Interesting.
The course format has evolved
from a weekly two-hour course
taking place over
an entire semester
and turned into an
intensive three-day program.
This change has created
more interest in the program
and allowed more
and more students
to not only pass the FAA exam,
which is the course's intended
goal, but to go on and actually
earn their Private Pilot
Certificate.
TINA SRIVASTAVA:
So I got engaged
in the course 16.687, the
Private Pilot Ground School,
in 2015.
At the time, I was completing
my doctorate at MIT,
and as we continued teach
the course, over time,
we discussed the
potential of changing
the structure of the
course, and last year
was the first time we changed
the structure of the course.
So instead of being
two-hour lectures
in the evenings over the
full spring semester,
it became the three-day
intensive course.
In the new learning
format, I think
the advantages are that the
students can focus exclusively
on this course for three days.
SARAH HANSEN: Sure.
TINA SRIVASTAVA: So they're not
distracted with other courses
or other activities.
They're just focused and
living and breathing everything
about becoming a pilot
that's necessary,
and I think that
level of engagement
has a different
set of advantages.
And so last year was the
pilot of the new format,
and it was very
successful in many ways.
We had about 101 students
on the first day,
and we completed the course
with about 98 students.
That was a big
accomplishment, and we
engaged a lot of
the students again,
in terms of not only completing
and passing the FAA exam
but continuing that enthusiasm
and getting their Private Pilot
Certificate.
SARAH HANSEN: In my conversation
with Philip and Tina,
it became clear that
there was something
important about having
this class meet in person.
It seems like exactly the kind
of content that might easily
be converted to
an online format,
but there was something that
made an in-person gathering not
just useful but essential here.
So I asked them, why
not just do this online?
PHILIP GREENSPUN:
So MIT students
are really good at reading
books, and this material,
to pass the test, you can
self-study successfully.
People do that at
commercial flight schools.
They just go home, and they
read all the FAA books which
are available online in PDF.
So yes, you have
to ask yourself,
what's the purpose
of even having
lecture halls and a university,
when there is so much available
online, and when you have
a population of people
who are great readers?
And reading is three times
faster than listening,
in terms of just being able
to get through information.
So that was part of
why we said, well,
look, we can do
this in three days,
because we're not going
to try to cover everything
and spoon feed it to people.
They can read the book.
So we'll ask them to do a
little bit of pre-reading,
and they we'll
inspire them, we hope,
with the in-person
experience, and then
they can go back to the books.
Whereas, I think the
traditional class
assumes that people
don't have access
to a lot of information
outside of the course.
SARAH HANSEN: I see.
PHILIP GREENSPUN:
Or that they have
to be just guided, where they'll
spoon-feed you with a problem
set or a reading assignment.
TINA SRIVASTAVA:
Yes, absolutely.
I would even say that less
than half of the course
was about the FAA
knowledge of them,
and the reason I
would say that is
that I think that so
much more of the course
was about becoming a pilot.
A lot of the discussion
and the interaction
and the interactive
discussions were really
focused on decision-making which
is very critical for a pilot.
Just because you can
answer a factual question
about the weather, for
example, doesn't necessarily
mean you've fully evaluated
whether it is safe to fly,
whether there are alternate
options available, how
you go through that whole
decision-making process.
We discuss everything from
aircraft ownership, shared
rentals, flying with
friends, going on vacations,
to really try to
share with students
how they could be
empowered as a pilot,
and we provided a lot
of tips and insight
from our own flying experience.
For example, in the
case of night flying,
the idea of trying to
take off before the sun
has set, so that you begin
to acclimate to the night
environment over time.
These types of insights
and experiences
are not part of the
FAA knowledge exam
but were some of the
most important pieces
of the course based on the
student feedback we received.
So it's really about
what the students are
interested in and engaged in.
Throughout the
three-day class, we also
have a number of breaks,
and at every single break,
we would have students come up
and either share an experience
or ask a question or
for clarification.
And that type of
feedback also helps
us inform how we
taught the class
and how we connected different
elements of the course
together to help
answer or provide
some enlightenment
on a particular topic
and how it relates
to other topics.
SARAH HANSEN: One
of the things I
was most curious about was
how Tina and Philip were
able to bring over 100 students
working at different paces
through this material.
These classes are often
so full that there's
a whole other overflow classroom
to accommodate the numbers.
What does it take to do that?
TINA SRIVASTAVA: One
of the ways that we
engage them is a traditional
method of just asking
a lot of questions,
and we would call up
students to answer them.
So we had a very
engaged group of folks.
Sometimes, we'd asked
questions, where
we'd ask students to raise
their hand to give us an answer,
and sometimes, we'd ask
students to shout out an answer.
SARAH HANSEN: OK.
TINA SRIVASTAVA:
A couple of times,
we used some FAA
practice exam questions,
and we would have students
raise their hands,
whether they thought
it was A, B, or C.
And depending on how divided
students were on the answer,
we knew whether we needed to
spend more time on the topic
or not.
So for example, one of the
questions that we asked them
was a real question from
the FAA exam and a question
that I got on my own FAA exam
which was about right of way,
when you're flying.
SARAH HANSEN: OK.
TINA SRIVASTAVA: So it
was, if you're flying,
and there is an
aircraft refueling
another aircraft, a
glider and a blimp,
which has the right of way?
SARAH HANSEN: Oh.
TINA SRIVASTAVA: And this
was a really good question,
and it generated a lot of
differences of opinion.
We had basically a
split of students
guessing all of three options.
So I'll leave that
interesting question there
without the answer,
so you'll have
to view the course to find out.
PHILIP GREENSPUN: Yeah.
I guess what I would add is
that it was good to have--
we had fairly frequent coffee
breaks and a pizza break,
but a lot of it was--
the slide presentation
to the students--
was really there
to set the stage.
And just having Tina there
with a PhD in aero-astro,
that's way above and
beyond what people
would have available
in a typical flight
school to really look at
the engineering trade-offs
instead of just saying,
this is how it works.
Here's your Cessna.
It converged on this design
sometime between the '30s
and '40s.
One good thing about aviation
is there's a huge amount
of government-produced stuff.
The FAA has done a
good to great job
about making graphics available
for every kind of aviation
topic.
So we mined a lot of this public
domain material from the FAA.
SARAH HANSEN: While
having these materials
accessible in the
public domain can
be a real boon to anyone
teaching complex materials,
it's rarely enough just
to point to the resources
and expect the
knowledge to sink in.
I wanted to know how these
elaborate and math-intensive
concepts were conveyed
to students in a way that
empowered them not only to
pass the FAA knowledge test
but to be informed,
practicing pilots.
To conclude our conversation,
I asked Tina and Philip
how they go about creating
clear and useful instruction
on complex topics, and they
told me about a critical lesson
in the class,
weight and balance.
TINA SRIVASTAVA: For
weight and balance,
what you're talking about is how
you load the aircraft, in terms
of the fuel, the
passengers, the baggage,
and how that affects the flight.
And so we used a
physical model airplane
to really demonstrate the
effect on an airplane,
if your center of gravity was
too far aft on the airplane.
We also solicited input
from the classroom
regarding their weight
and weights of bags.
We gave them some
insights and tips
that whenever they're flying
to not necessarily trust
what their passengers
tell them is
the weight, their own weight.
So to be safety conscious,
maybe apply a factor of safety
on what your friend tells
you that they weight,
and we used a book to show
how you can do calculations.
And we also went live online to
the website of certain flight
schools to show how you can
find the exact gross weight
and loading characteristics
of different aircraft
and different online
calculators that
calculate weight and balance
for you and project that.
And then finally,
we also showed how
to do those calculations on
an iPad with foreign flights.
So we showed, again,
different ways
to approach the same
information and materials.
So that it wasn't just an
academic description of how
to calculate weight
and balance, but truly
how they would do
that as a pilot,
not just the FAA
regulations for it,
but how they would go about
doing that for a flight
that they fly on.
[PLANE ENGINE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH HANSEN: If you're
interested in learning more
about becoming a pilot or just
about the flight school itself,
you can find the
flight school materials
on our website at ocw.mit.edu.
And if you're an educator,
check out our special portal
on the site just for you
at ocw.mit.edu/educator.
Thank you so much for
listening, and if you
like what you've
heard so far, please
consider subscribing
and leaving us a review.
Until next time, I'm
Sarah Hansen from OCW.
[MUSIC PLAYING]